in his State of the Union address
President Trump talked about unity but
he did not back down on the issues that
had divided the parties the president
insisted he will build a wall along the
southern border he did not mention the
35 day partial government shutdown and
only touched briefly on the next week's
deadline for another possible shutdown
this image had a lot of people
responding its of House Speaker Nancy
Pelosi giving a sideways clap and a bit
of a sideways smile as she responds with
skepticism to the president's call to
end revenge politics that picture of
course encapsulating much of the evening
we heard the president deliver the
speech in front of dozens of New
Democratic women you saw them all
dressed in white in support of
suffragists in support of women's rights
many of them wearing er a buttons as
well and in fact the president drew one
of his biggest cheers of the entire
evening when he acknowledged them
exactly one century after Congress
passed the constitutional amendment
giving women the right to vote we also
have more women serving in Congress than
at any time before
and CBS News took a poll of people who
watched the speech and it found opinions
split along party lines 97% of
Republicans approving an eighty-two
percent of Democrats less so among the
Democrats major Garrett is at the white
house major good morning good morning
president Trump began the speech with a
call for bipartisanship he ended it with
a bid for what he called new American
greatness in the middle some soothing
words about domestic policies Democrats
have supported but he also implied
Democrats are radical on the issue of
abortion and embracing socialism with
another government shutdown looming the
centerpiece issue remained immigration
and the ongoing legislative fight over a
border wall the agenda I will lay out
this evening is not a Republican agenda
or a Democrat agenda
it's the agenda of the American people a
typically combative President came with
an olive branch to the democratically
controlled house chamber a place he was
denied access during the partial
government shutdown the state of our
union is strong to avoid another
shutdown in ten days the president will
need a border security deal he called
for compromise
I stand here ready to work with you mr.
Trump boasted about job and wage growth
suggested troop withdrawals were coming
in Afghanistan and Syria and announced a
second summit with North Korea leader
Kim jong-un in Vietnam in three weeks if
I had not been elected president of the
United States we would right now in my
opinion be in a major war with North
Korea and in a sign of things to come
the president previewed a new defense
against House Democrats gearing up to
investigate many aspects of his
administration an economic miracle is
taking place in the United States and
the only thing that can stop it are
foolish Wars politics or ridiculous
partisan investigations
the president stuck to his hostile
rhetoric about illegal immigration
referencing gangs drug dealers and human
traffickers as threats to American
citizens tolerance for illegal
immigration is not compassionate it is
actually very cruel funding for a
boarder barrier remains a sticking point
with Democrats and for Republicans
queasy about another shutdown mr. Trump
made this vow the proper wall never got
built I will get it built some of the
president's immigration language drew
Democratic groans unable to get his way
with the former Republican House on
immigration mr. Trump faced a different
move and look as scores of women
lawmakers wore white to represent the
suffragette movement they shared the
spotlight with guests of the first
family in June I commuted Alice's sense
like Alice Johnson first time nonviolent
drug offender released from prison last
June officer Matson please Timothy
Matson a SWAT officer who was shot while
chasing the killer during the Pittsburgh
synagogue shooting and Judas amat a
Holocaust survivor who also survived the
Pittsburgh synagogue shooting
celebrating his 81st birthday
brought the room together in song after
the speech House Speaker Nancy Pelosi
applauded the president for noting the
historically high number of women in
Congress though she pointed out the vast
majority are Democrats and many of them
ran to oppose mr. Trump's agenda viana
good point major thank you